Welcome back to the next episode of
What's Up, Prof.
Hello, Walter.
Good day again. It's nice to see you.
You look nice and chirpy today. You look
chirpy, too.
Thank you.
Uh
Before we begin and pray and everything,
um maybe you can just explain to us what
is
what this is.
Like
I don't know what that
I haven't got the foggiest idea.
I think it's a decoration
that uh
they bought this
because it's the same color of this. I
don't know. Maybe it's a a fruit from
this pine here. I don't
I don't know what it is. I think you can
put a candle in there.
Yeah, maybe. But it's a But then this
one doesn't have anything on it. So,
it's just a decoration. The advantage is
that if you put a candle in there, then
the candle will be higher than when you
put it down there. Yes. So,
thank you for that explanation.
pleasure. So, let's open up with a word
of prayer. Will you pray for us now?
Thanks.
Our loving heavenly Father,
we are living in such troublesome times.
The world is on fire,
but
you want our hearts to be right.
And I pray that you will help us and
lead us with your Holy Spirit
so that we may discern not only the
times we live in,
but what you would have us be.
So, help us in our deliberations in
Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
So, we've been busy
discussing the pillars of Adventism.
Yes. And we only got as far as the
sanctuary with the previous episode.
Correct. So, is there any Would you like
to carry on and show us what is
interesting on
Well, when we looked at
this issue,
we said there were five pillars of
Adventism.
Now, last time we discussed the
sanctuary doctrine
and that there is a sanctuary in heaven
and that Jesus went into
the holy and then the most holy. into
the most holy and what the cleansing of
the sanctuary
meant and all of those issue issues.
I think the doctrine of the second
advent, I think we've discussed that
quite thoroughly. Yes, I think so. I
don't think we have to go into that and
you've given all the links The links is
where people can study that. The
Sabbath, I think we have dealt with
dealt with in quite some detail.
The state of the dead, perhaps we can do
that at the stage as well.
Spirit of prophecy, we had a whole
lecture on that if I recall.
So, what else is on this slide? Out of
these, the realization emerged of the
context of the three angels' messages
that had to be preached to the whole
world and the health message was later
added
because uh it was considered the right
arm of the gospel. Mhm.
This causes
a little bit of perplexity Yes.
in some people because why should there
be a health message associated, you
know, with the gospel?
So, maybe we can talk about that. We
can. If I can just go back to the um
sanctuary doctrine, there was a question
Yes. about You mentioned
in the lecture the scapegoat. Mhm. And
somebody asked, and I think that's a
question that a lot of people actually
ask,
who does the scapegoat represent? Uh
okay.
Well, remember there were two goats on
the Day of Atonement. Now, the Day of
Atonement in
Jewish thinking
was the day of judgment. Mhm. So, on
that day, they would fast.
They would uh search their souls to see
what is inside of them. In other words,
they'll do introspection to see whether
they are right with God. It was a solemn
day. Mhm.
And on that day, they had to bring two
goats.
And they cast lots for
the goats and then when the lot was had
determined, one of them became the
Lord's goat Mhm. and the other one
became the scapegoat.
Now, the Lord's goat was sacrificed
and the high priest took of that blood
into the sanctuary and he went into the
most holy. It was a very solemn
occasion.
And uh remember they had little bells
around the bottom and everybody was
listening carefully because in the past
it had happened that if someone was
careless
Mhm. and they went into the most holy or
weren't entitled to be there, they could
be struck dead. Mhm.
So, there was a lot of introspection. Am
I right with God? And the high priest
would go in
and he would make atonement for the
sanctuary.
Now, obviously the sanctuary doesn't
sin. It's a building, right? Yes. Or
it's a structure. Mhm.
So, what kind of atonement? Atonement is
uh
Well, let's put it this way. Tyndale put
it nicely. He actually coined the
phrase.
It meant at-one-ment. Okay. Atonement.
Yeah. At-one-ment. It's actually a
word that he made up to explain how God
um associated himself with humanity and
became one with them and took the place
of and paid the price for as though he
were the guilty party, although he
wasn't. Yes.
And so, you when you when they made
atonement for the sanctuary, the record
of sin was removed. These are all the
confessed sins. Now, remember Jesus had
already paid the price for those sins
and the price was death. Yes.
The wages of sin
is death. So, the price for those sins
has been fully paid. Yeah.
In fact,
the price for all sin
for all of humanity was paid on the
cross.
Yes.
But not everybody appropriates it.
Only those who confess their sins and
forsake their sins
are those sins that are carried into the
sanctuary.
Now, so the redeemed sins, the record of
sin is there.
Now, that record of sin has to be
removed.
And this is what happened on the Day of
Atonement. So, in type,
he removed the record of sin and it
started in the most holy. Mhm.
And he sprinkled the blood
on the ark of the covenant. Remember the
ark of the covenant contained the 10
Commandments, which are the standard of
God's righteousness and his law. Yes.
The 10 Commandments condemned me to
death.
And so, in type, the condemnation
is removed. The sin, the recorded sin on
the horns of the alt- altar is removed
as he moves into the holy. The whole
structure, everything that dealt with
how to deal with the sin sin issue is
basically removed, the record of
confessed sin. Yes.
And then the high priest would, in type,
place his hands upon the scapegoat. Mhm.
And in type, the record of confessed
sins, that had already been atoned for
by the blood of Jesus Christ,
was placed on the scapegoat. But the
scapegoat doesn't die at that point.
Mhm.
He is led into the wilderness Yes. by a
strong man.
And then he is let loose.
Now, what does that entail and who is
the scapegoat?
Well, the scapegoat was also known as
Azazel, Mhm. which is a symbol of the
devil. Mhm. So, who actually initiated
sin in the universe? It was the devil.
Yes. And who caused man to sin?
It was the devil that caused man to sin.
Now, some people cling to sin
and some people are willing to forsake
sin. And all those records of of
forsaken, forgiven sins
are placed onto the scapegoat, the real
culprit who actually produced those
sins. Yes. But he doesn't become the sin
bearer because he doesn't pay the price
for those sins. He doesn't die. He
doesn't shed his blood for those sins.
Yes.
That sin stays on his head.
on his head. Now, the beauty of this
is that when the record of sin is
removed from heaven,
then you stand before God as though you
had never sinned. So, how complete is
forgiveness?
Complete.
It's absolute. There is not even a
record of sin. It has been removed.
Yes.
And eventually
when
God's retributive action takes place and
humanity
in the final judgment
comes under the condemnation
and everybody that has
decided to cling to their sin
will pay the price for that sin, which
is death. Yes.
And fire came out of heaven and consumed
them. They shall be ashes under your
feet. They were consumed away, says the
Bible.
Nothing left.
So, everybody that has never confessed
their sins will pay the price for those
sins. Yes. They could have had
redemption because Christ had died for
those sins already.
But they didn't appropriate them. They
didn't want that atonement. Yes, they
cling to something for themselves.
Exactly. And God doesn't force anyone.
Yes. So, then you pay the price. But if
you have forsaken and confessed your
sins
and accepted the free gift of Christ's
sacrifice
then you don't come into condemnation.
Yes.
But that record is still there. Mhm.
And that record has to be removed from
heaven. Heaven is a place of
sinlessness. Yes. There's not even a
record of sin. So, even that is removed
and placed upon the scapegoat. And
eventually after the millennium
when
sin is destroyed and the devil is
destroyed as well because the Bible says
fire came out of him devouring
and consumed him. He was gone.
So, that record together with him is
destroyed forever.
I think that was very nice and clear.
So, let's let's move on to the the next
the health message that you
and what can you Yes, people ask this
question. Why should there be
a health message? What has health got to
do with the gospel?
And the answer is quite a deal.
So, let us go through some of these
these things and see
what we can find.
When God created an Adam and Eve
and he put them in the garden
he determined what their diet should be.
So, if we go to Genesis chapter 1 verse
29 and it says
And God said, "Behold, I have given you
every herb bearing seed, which is upon
the face of all the earth.
And every tree in which is the fruit of
a tree yielding seed, to you it shall be
for meat."
Now, we must remember this is old
English when it says meat, it means
food.
When it says flesh, it means meat as we
would say it today.
All right. So, what was the first diet
of man?
It was every plant, every herb that
bears seed. So, that's all your grains
and your seeds
which is upon the face of the whole
earth and every tree
in which is the fruit of a tree yielding
seed. So, fruits grains nuts seeds, that
was the diet of man.
No vegetables. Yes.
None.
Now, what was the diet of the animals?
Genesis 1 verse 30 says, "And to every
beast of the earth and to every fowl
Every is a very big word, you Yes, that
doesn't exclude any. No, it doesn't
exclude anything.
Every beast of the earth and every fowl
of the air and to everything that
creepeth upon the earth wherein there is
life, I have given every green herb for
meat. And it was so. Mhm. So, all the
green plants.
So, you have your grazers that graze,
you have your
browsers that eat leaves.
That was the food. And some had
specialized foods. Now, we must
understand
that the antediluvian world was a very,
very rich world
and the climate was absolutely
perfect.
And
the the plants that EXISTED FAR exceeded
in number those that we have today.
I mean, if you take the great oil
deposits in the world, the great coal
fields in the world, these are all plant
materials from the antediluvian world
that were destroyed in the
yes. Yeah.
And if you go into the paleontological
record, we find
myriads of animals and plants that no
longer exist.
So, there were was a plant for every
single animal.
Now, I once gave
a lecture called Creation to
Restoration. Perhaps you could put that
link in.
Yes, we can see how the animal kingdom
originally was all plant eating. And how
we still find evidence for that today
even in the big carnivores like the
lions, etc.
So, the Bible says everything ate
plants. That was the diet of man.
And it's obvious there was no death.
Death is a consequence of sin.
So, the plant world was created as food.
Now, the Bible also says that
the life is in the blood.
Now, plants
don't have a vascular system. They have
other
tubular systems, xylem and phloem, etc.,
etc. But it's not a vascular system.
They also don't have a nervous system.
But they are living. They're living
food. Living food.
And in Genesis 3 verse 17
there is this statement. And unto Adam
he said, "Because thou hast hearkened
unto the voice of thy wife
uh that's a very interesting verse. I
don't think we should get into that. We
get into trouble if we if we go down
that route.
And has eaten of the tree of which I
commanded thee saying, Thou shalt not
eat of it, cursed is the ground
for thy sake.
So, what was cursed? The ground.
Yes.
In sorrow shalt thou eat of it all the
days of thy life. Thorns also and
thistles shall it bring forth to thee,
and thou shalt eat the herbs of the
field.
So, after sin came into the world,
something was added to the diet.
The herbs of the field.
Which originally were animal food.
So, in other words, what happened here
was vegetables were added. All the leafy
plants that we eat were added to the
diet. Now, why? Obviously to augment the
diet
and to supply
nutrients.
Nutrients because after the sin, the
earth was cursed. Correct. So, when
earth was cursed, then it didn't bring
forth as it did before.
And there was also a seasonality.
We know that the Bible tells us that the
trees, take the tree of life for example
bore fruit once a month.
So, that's 12 times a year. We don't
have that luxury today.
So, certain fruits are seasonal.
And what if you have certain areas where
well, there is no fruit during a certain
season like in Europe for example
or in the very cold areas. Well, then
you have to eat the plants of the field.
That's the way it is. Now why was diet
so important? Do you remember that diet
was the first test? Mhm.
You shall not eat of this tree. And it
was it looked good for food. So, why
would God make such a rule?
And it was it was a test of faith,
right? Yes. So, does faith and diet have
something to do with each other? I think
so.
So
could it be a test? Mhm. What Yes, I
think as we go on, you'll see that it
did become a test eventually for a few
except for Adam and Eve and a few other
places as well. Correct. Now, the other
thing that's interesting is
uh
this was the very first thing that
created
the fall.
And when you go to the temptations of
Jesus
what was the very first temptation?
Turn the stone into bread. Aha. In other
words
where Adam and Eve had all this luxury
that surrounded them
the son of God was in that wilderness
and he had been fasting for 40 days. He
was emaciated.
He was
hungry to the point of death.
And he was tempted
on the issue of diet.
And in behalf of humanity
he redeemed Adam's fall.
So, diet obviously played a very
important
Exactly, but like you said now, in
exactly what Adam fell to sin, he
overcame
not to sin. Correct. Absolutely.
When we talk about uh
the other one, of course, was uh the sin
of presumption. Mhm.
Throw yourself down. But we're not going
to go into that.
Yeah, that's a whole lecture on the
subject.
of its by itself, yeah. So, we read in
the spirit of prophecy, God gave our
first parents the food he designed that
the race should eat.
It was contrary to his plan to have the
life of any creature taken. That's
obvious. The wages of sin is death.
There was to be no death in Eden. The
fruit of the trees in the garden was the
food man's wants required. God gave man
no permission to eat animal food until
after the flood.
Everything had been destroyed upon which
man could subsist, and therefore the
Lord in their necessity gave Noah
permission to eat of the clean animals.
Now, this is very important
because people say, you know, clean and
unclean doesn't count anymore. Mhm.
But uh
here we see that clean and unclean
existed in Noah's day already.
Because he had to take seven pairs of
clean
and one pair of unclean animals.
Yes.
Uh usually, if you ask people how many
of each animal went into the ark,
everybody will say two.
Yeah, one pair. One pair. Yes. But just
mention again
of the unclean, it was a pair. Yes. Of
the clean, it's much more.
So, when he brought an offering
cuz he offered the clean animals at the
when he when the flood was over,
he couldn't offer the unclean
because that would have destroyed the
race, right? So, or the kind, in any
case. So, clean and unclean is something
that existed before the flood, and Noah
was specifically told that he wasn't to
eat the fat
or the blood.
Mhm.
So, no blood, no fat, and nothing that
is unclean. Now, people will say,
"Yes, but uh God declared these things
clean." When Jesus said he declares it
clean. Now, this is where the the Bible
translations again become interesting.
And unfortunately, it just is a fact
that the modern translations just don't
do justice to what is really said
uh
in the NIV, for example, it will say
that when when Jesus said it's not what
goes into your mouth that makes you
unclean, but what comes out of your
mouth that makes you unclean.
Mhm.
It says there quite categorically in the
new translations in the NIV, "Hereby
Jesus declared all foods clean."
Clean.
Well, if that were the case, are you
going to eat uh poisonous animals that
will kill you with one lick?
I mean, that's a ridiculous statement.
And they will claim, "Well, Peter had
the vision, remember?"
Yes, so that But uh what was Peter's
answer three times when he was told,
Yeah.
"Peter, go kill and eat, and do not say
that is unclean what God has declared
clean."
While he was sitting there wondering
what the vision meant, because he had
said, "Not so, my Lord. I have never
eaten anything impure or unclean."
So,
while he was thinking, there was this
knock on the door.
And the three men stood there, remember?
Yes.
And when he came to Cornelius's house,
he said, "God has shown me
Exactly.
that I should call no man impure or
unclean." It had nothing to do with
diet.
Yeah. So, uh those rules have been
absolutely obliterated by humanity. Mhm.
Uh so, what were the prohibitions? No
fat, no blood,
no blood, nothing unclean
in terms of diet. But what was the
original diet? Yes, totally plant-based.
So, if God wanted to restore humanity to
the original,
uh
or let's rephrase that.
Is God going to restore humanity to the
original? Yes. So, what will they have
to give up?
All these
foods that weren't part of the original
diet. They will have to be given up. Uh
is it better to do it sooner or later?
And was there another issue? Was there a
spiritual issue? And that's what we're
going to talk about, because we're
talking about
preparation for the Lord's coming.
As I said, I believe that the signs are
fulfilling around us. I don't Do you
feel that? Oh, definitely.
Do you Can you see uh
the predictions in the book of
Revelation coming to fruition? Can you
see the image of the beast forming? Yes,
definitely.
We can see all these signs around us.
So, if all of these things are
happening,
then know that the time is near.
So, God gave man no permission to eat
animal food until after the flood, and
we discussed that. Everything had been
destroyed upon which man could subsist,
and therefore the Lord in their
necessity gave Noah permission to eat of
the clean animals, which he had taken
with him into the ark.
But animal food was not the most
healthful article of food for man.
So, why did God permit this? Well, there
was nothing else.
Uh
what was the consequence? Well, before
the flood, people reached ages of over
900 years.
Yes.
The
very next generation after the flood
only reached half of that. Yes. Around
400 and something.
And then as you continue down the line,
you will see that it became less and
less. In the time of Abraham, Abraham
was 180. Yes.
By the time you get to
Moses, it's 120.
years. By the time you get to David,
it's 70, and if you're lucky, you reach
80, and by reason of strength, you might
get to be more than that.
So, animal food was never the most
healthful article of food for man.
Purely on a physical basis.
But what about the mental basis? And I
think that is something
that we can look at.
So, after the flood, people ate largely
animal food. God saw that the ways of
man were corrupt, and that he was
disposed to exalt himself proudly
against his creator and to follow the
inclinations of his own heart.
And he permitted that long-lived race to
eat animal food to shorten their sinful
lives.
Actually, that's also a mercy.
Soon after the flood, the race began to
rapidly decrease in size and in length
of years. Well, you can check that in
the Bible, but the words of our teacher
to us were, "As a man thinketh, so is
he."
The flesh of dead animals was not the
original food for man. Man was permitted
to eat it after the flood because all
vegetation had been destroyed. But the
curse pronounced upon man and earth and
every living thing has made strange and
wonderful changes. Since the flood, the
human race has been shortening its
period of existence,
physical, mental, moral degeneracy
is rapidly increasing in these latter
days.
Uh
that is a fact.
I mean,
I've been around for more than a
generation.
I'm heading for the second generation.
And
even I can say that in my lifetime, I
have seen massive changes
in terms of moral degeneracy amongst
mankind. Yes. I mean, what was
absolutely abhorred in the past is now
legislation.
Yes. Yes, I'm I'm afraid if it carries
on like this, all these things will
become compulsory.
So, we said that the the animal kingdom
and humanity will be restored to the
original. Does the Bible tell us that?
Let's have a look.
The answer is yes. Isaiah 11:6.
And the wolf also shall dwell with the
lamb, and the leopard shall lie down
with the kid. So, there will be no more
predation.
And the calf and the young lion and the
fatling together, and a little child
shall lead them. In other words, no
aggression.
You don't have to be afraid.
And the cow and the bear shall feed, and
the young ones shall lie down together,
and the lion will become a vegetarian.
Mhm.
He will eat straw like the ox. So, what
kind of straw he will eat, we don't
know. What was the original grass form?
Reed, perhaps? Because we do have
carnivores that eat reeds, like panda
bears, for example.
So, maybe there was a specific uh
reed or grass kind that was lion food,
that required those shearing teeth to
shred it like the panda bear in his
case.
But then there's this interesting verse
11, Isaiah 11:11, "And it shall come to
pass in that day
that the Lord shall send set his hand
again the second time
to recover the remnant of his people
which shall be left from Assyria and
from Egypt and from Pathros and from
Cush and from Elam and from Shinar and
from Hamath and from the islands of the
sea." So now he's going to a universal
scale.
And he says God is going to gather his
people a second time.
And he shall set up an ensign for the
nations and shall
assemble the outcasts of Israel and
gather together the dispersed of Judah
from the four corners of the earth. God
is going to call a people
at the end of time and he's going to
bring them into a relationship with
himself. Now,
what did he do when he called Israel out
of Egypt?
Put them on a diet. Aha. So he put them
on a road of experiential
learning.
Mhm.
And diet was an integral part of that
event. So when God took the children of
Israel out of Egypt and he brought them
into this relationship with himself,
he was
intent on training them to become
Eden-minded again.
Yes.
Uh they were very charmed with that,
right?
No.
So when God gathers the people
universally for the second time,
do you think he might follow a
a similar process or will he say, "Well,
it didn't work the first time. I'm going
to leave that one out." Mhm. I don't
think so.
And are the people going to feel
differently than they they felt when
they came out of Egypt about this new
way that God or this way that God wants
them to Well, when God calls people, he
calls all kinds of people, doesn't he?
Yes. But it's a good question. I I think
you have an ulterior motive.
I know.
So when
when he calls them out and he brings
them into this relationship,
uh were they all holy people, wonderful
people when he called them out? No,
there were also others amongst them
which were called the mixed multitude.
Uh there was always strife and argument.
And we can have a similar situation.
God calls
all kinds of people. The gospel net
catches all kinds of fish.
And they're brought into the gospel net.
But the sorting of the fish
is God's business and not my business.
So God will one day sort the bad fish
from the good fish and he will sort the
good grain from the tares. Yes, from the
tares, etc. So let's have a look because
people sometimes will claim, "Oh, you
Adventists, you make health such a big
issue." Mhm.
But why is it a big issue?
And let's get a biblical basis for this
because it really is biblical.
So what did God do when he let the
children of Israel out of out of Egypt?
Let's have a look at the Exodus. Exodus
16:2.
And the whole congregation of the
children of Israel murmured against
Moses and Aaron in the wilderness.
And the children of Israel said unto
them,
"Would to God we had died by the hand of
the Lord in the land of Egypt when we
sat by the flesh pots." Now this is not
meat, right? This is flesh.
"And when we did eat bread to the full,
for you have brought us forth into this
wilderness to kill this whole assembly
with hunger."
Then said the Lord unto Moses, "Behold,
I will rain bread from heaven for you.
And the people shall go out and gather a
certain rate every day
that I may prove them whether they will
walk in my law or not."
It's interesting.
Mhm. So
diet was associated with law.
Yes. Now
when the bread fell, the manna,
of course on a Friday there was a double
portion.
On the Sabbath there was none. Mhm. And
some of them would try and go and gather
it on the on the Sabbath, but there was
none.
And if they gathered more than they
should on the other days, then it became
rotten.
Yes.
Now what was the lesson in that?
The manna, of course, was the literal
food, but it had a spiritual application
pointing to a higher food, the bread
that came down from heaven, namely Jesus
Christ and his character.
And that internalization, this study of
the character of God, is a daily Yes. I
cannot
uh hoard and gorge myself in that for a
day and then go without it
because I feel that I've had enough. No,
I need a daily experience with God. And
so it was a test of obedience whether
they would recognize the Sabbath. And
remember, this was before Sinai. Yes. So
the law had not yet been given. And it
came to pass that on the sixth day they
shall prepare that which they bring in
and it shall be twice as much as they
gather daily.
So by a singular miracle,
God drilled the Sabbath into their
minds.
Yes. Important, right?
Definitely. Okay. Now that was the type.
Don't you think when God gathers the
people out of the world for the second
time that he will do the same? Yes. That
he will drill this concept of the
Sabbath into the minds of men.
Therefore, on the sixth day
there will be none. You have to have
prepared yourself. You have to have the
preparation before that and then you
must concentrate on the Sabbath day.
And there will be twice as much, so you
won't starve. No. God will take care of
you on the Sabbath day. And Moses said,
"This shall be when the Lord shall give
you in the evening flesh to eat
and in the morning bread to the full.
Now why did he give them flesh? Because
they were murmuring for it. Aha.
He didn't originally give it to them.
No.
But they got fed up with the kind of
food that they were getting
and so they murmured.
Because you murmured against him.
And what are we? Your murmurings are not
against us, but against the Lord because
who instigated this rule?
It was God.
Yes. God wanted to take them back to
have uh
Edenic diet and a Edenic mindset.
Verse 12 says, "And I have heard the
murmurings of the children of Israel,
speak unto them." says God now.
"At even you shall eat flesh
and in the morning you shall be filled
with bread
and you shall know that I am the Lord
your God. I'll give you what you want.
The bread is from me, the other one is
because of your murmuring."
And the children of Israel did eat manna
40 years until they came to a land
inhabited.
They did eat manna until they came into
the borders of the land of Canaan. Well,
if you're an American, you say manna,
right?
Now why?
Deuteronomy 8:3,
"And he humbled thee
and suffered thee to hunger
and fed thee with manna
which thou knewest not, neither did thy
fathers know, that he might make thee
know that man does not live by bread
alone, but by every word that proceeds
out of the mouth of the Lord doth man
live."
So
diet
associated with God's word.
Yes.
And if diet has a role to play in your
association with the word, then it must
have a important part to play in
discernment.
Yes.
And we have to get into the
bottom of to the bottom of this.
When he gave them meat, he gave them
another specific instruction. In Numbers
11:18, he says,
"And say unto the people, sanctify
yourselves against tomorrow."
That's a fascinating statement.
Contemplate
your standing with God and see that you
are right with God and whether you are
in God's will.
And then you shall eat flesh for you
have wept in the ears of the Lord saying
who shall give us flesh to eat. Can we
expect the people in the second
gathering to have similar sentiments?
Now you are conjecturing something.
Well, I can only give my own experience.
I was probably
the biggest meat eater on the planet.
Uh
chicken to me was a vegetable. Yeah.
Steak was was meat, was flesh, right?
Well, that's the South African view of
well,
chicken. It's vegetable. It's definitely
a vegetable.
So, it was very very strange to me to
see a people trying to live on a
plant-based diet. I thought it was
totally insane. Mhm.
And when I studied it,
uh I became even more convicted that
they were insane.
Yeah.
But then when I studied the word of God
and that little voice started speaking
to me,
and then of course the experience,
the sicknesses that came with it, the
frequent uh
colds, the the flus, the ear infections,
the throat infections, the sinus
infections, all of these things,
uh the high blood pressure, all of these
issues.
Then I started realizing that God's way
is the better way.
And it is a tremendous adjustment.
Mhm. Yes. But this is what we are all
like and some will yield it
and some won't.
So, God said to them, you shall not eat
one day,
nor two days, nor five days, neither 10
days, nor 20 days, but even a whole
month until it come out of your nostrils
and it is loathsome unto you. I think
he's trying to make a point, don't you?
Oh, yes.
Because you have despised the Lord which
is amongst you and have wept before him
saying, why came we forth out of Egypt?
So, it was pleased with their meat
eating, yes or no? Flesh eating.
According to this, no. Absolutely not.
Was he going to teach them a lesson? He
said so.
Numbers 21 verse 5, and this people
spoke against God and against Moses,
wherefore have you brought us up out of
Egypt to die in the wilderness for there
is no bread, neither is there any water.
Our soul loathes this light bread.
In other words, it wasn't heavy on the
stomach. It must have been very good for
them.
But they loathed it. They wanted
something substantial.
And
uh yes.
A man in particular is that way
inclined. He wants something
substantial,
not this
bread.
light green stuff, yeah.
Oh, yes.
Numbers 11:32.
And the people stood up all that day and
all that night and all the next day and
they gathered the quails. And he that
gathered least gathered 10 homers.
That's about a bath full. Yeah, 200 L
about.
Yeah.
And they spread them all abroad for
themselves around about the camp. And
while the Now, this is interesting.
While the flesh was yet between their
teeth,
ere it was chewed, Mhm.
the wrath of the Lord was kindled
against the people and the Lord smote
the people with a very great plague.
God was obviously not pleased with their
disposition, right?
And he called the name of that place
Kibroth-hattaavah,
graves of longing,
because there they buried the people
that lusted. That's very prophecy
actually tells us that they were so
gluttonous that they couldn't even wait
to to be properly cooked, mhm, nor
properly prepared.
And that they just started eating it
like like crazy. And some of course were
more gluttonous than others. It's also
interesting when you study the word
gluttony, Mhm.
you will find in in the scripture,
especially in writings of Solomon,
that it's particularly associated with
meat eating, flesh eating.
So, some of them were more so than
others and they of course were the first
ones to actually suffer the
consequences.
And verse 6 had said, now our soul is
dried away.
That's interesting.
There's nothing at all beside this manna
before our eyes.
So, something happens inside when you
start desiring
foods that are not good for you. Mhm.
Verse 31 says, and there went forth a
wind from the Lord and brought quails
from the sea and let them fall by the
camp as it were a day's journey on this
side and as it were a day's journey on
the other side round about the camp and
as it were two cubits high upon the face
of the earth.
So, here they were just sitting.
And some people say, well, you know
what? This was not a miracle. This was
just something that happened at that
time of year,
that the winds brought the birds and
they sat down and the people ate this,
but God did this twice. Yes.
The first time he was more lenient with
them. He told them he was displeased,
but the second time is when he sent the
plague. Yes. So, obviously God wanted
them to learn a lesson, but many of them
refused to learn the lesson.
And Psalms gives us a little bit of an
inkling here. Psalms 106 verse 14.
But they lusted exceedingly in the
wilderness
and tempted God in the desert.
This is this is like Hebrew parallelism.
Mhm.
So, the lusting
is associated with tempting God. In
other words, you're going against God's
will, best will for you.
Uh verse 15 says, and he gave them their
request.
But then this amazing verse here,
but sent leanness into their soul.
Something happened in here.
A leanness, an emptiness.
Emptiness.
So,
has it to do with discernment?
So, can obedience in terms of diet
affect your spirituality?
You know, I always found it fascinating
cuz I was associated with the occult
world.
And I studied a lot about occultism when
I was a pagan.
And my father-in-law was deeply involved
and he actually trained me in many many
things.
And
we all ate meat, of course. But
when he wanted to be on a different
spiritual level,
when he wanted to have a particular
spiritual experience,
he'll go vegetarian.
And if you read the occult writings, you
will see that many of the high
Luciferians are actually vegetarians.
And many of the leaders in the world are
vegetarians.
So, even in the occult world,
spirituality can be associated with your
diet.
Mhm.
Yes.
Yeah, because Satan, the father of all
this, knows Absolutely.
that your diet has to do with your
spirituality.
Absolutely. And your spirituality can be
on the side of the Luciferian doctrine
or it can be on the side of the biblical
doctrine.
Yes.
Now, 1 Corinthians 10 verse 6 says, now
these things were our examples to the
intent that we should not lust of the
evil things as they also lusted. What
did they lust after? After the flesh
pots.
It's interesting to me that flesh in the
Bible is a symbol of the unsanctified
nature.
And the manna symbolizes the sanctified
Here's another quote that I found
fascinating. During this period of
waiting,
there was time for them to meditate upon
the law of God which they had heard and
to prepare their hearts to receive the
further revelations
that he might make to them. They had not
too much time for this work.
And had they been thus seeking a clearer
understanding of God's requirements and
humbling their hearts before him, they
would have been shielded from
temptation.
But they did not do this.
And they soon became careless,
inattentive,
lawless.
Especially was this the case with the
mixed multitude. They were impatient to
be on way to the land of promise, the
the land flowing with milk and honey. It
was only on condition of obedience that
the goodly land was promised them, but
they had lost sight of this.
There were some who suggested a return
to Egypt.
But whether forward to Canaan or
backward to Egypt, the masses of the
people were determined to wait no longer
for Moses.
So,
isn't that interesting
that your understanding
will be affected?
Mhm.
You know, I find uh the story of
Herod and John the Baptist very
interesting.
Yes.
Because Herod, actually, according to
the scripture, was very interested in
what John the Baptist had to say.
Yes.
And in fact, Manaen, his stepbrother,
accepted what John the Baptist said and
joined the church.
And Herod
actually changed many things in his
life.
But when Herodias couldn't get her way,
she organized a tremendous feast. Mhm.
And there was lots of wine and
everything that gratified the appetite.
And when under those beclouded
conditions,
suddenly,
his discernment was gone.
And he did things which he would not
normally do. Yes.
And he sentenced
him to death on the request of Herodias
through Salome. So, diet can so becloud
your attention and your mind
that it can cost you your eternal life.
Mhm.
Psalm 78:18 says, "And they tempted God
in their hearts by asking meat for their
lust."
Psalms 106:14
and 15, "They lusted exceedingly in the
wilderness, tempted God, and he gave
them their request, but this leanness in
the soul, this emptiness in the heart."
So, when they walked according to the
counsel of God, what happened? Psalms
105:37
says, "He brought them forth also with
silver and gold, and there was not one
feeble person amongst their tribes."
Yeah.
Healthy.
promise.
Mhm.
And here's another quote from the spirit
of prophecy.
The light that God has given and will
continue to give on the food question is
to be to his people today
what the manna was to the children of
Israel.
So, we do have a test.
Yes.
God does not change.
It says, "Jesus Christ is the same
yesterday, today, and
forever."
So, when he gathered them and he put
them on that lifestyle, when he gathers
them out of
the world, out of every nation, tribe,
and people, he's going to do the same.
And we're going to have the same
consequences.
Now, one interesting story in the Bible
that tells us what discernment is and
what diet what role diet plays is the
story of Daniel.
The character of Daniel is presented to
the world as a striking example of what
God's grace can make of men fallen by
nature and corrupted by sin.
The record of his noble, self-denying
life is an encouragement to our common
humanity.
From it, we may gather strength to nobly
resist temptation and firmly and in the
grace of meekness stand for the right
under the severest trials.
Those who make the most of their
opportunities, who place themselves in
right relation with God, will be
rewarded even as as was Daniel. We read
of him,
"Daniel purposed in his heart that he
would not defile himself with the
portion of the king's meat."
That's the king's food.
Mhm.
"Nor with the wine which he drank.
Therefore, he requested the prince of
the eunuchs that he might not defile
himself. Now, God had brought Daniel
into favor and tender love with the
prince of the eunuchs, and the prince of
the eunuchs said unto Daniel, 'I fear my
lord the king.'"
In other words,
he was under the impression that the
king's food was the best.
Yes.
Daniel said, "No, it's not the best."
And it came to a test.
"For why should I see your face worse
liking than the children which are of
your sort?"
So, here were the exiles. They were all
Israelites.
Yes. That's an important point, isn't
it?
Yes. And a lot of people miss that. Yes.
The first test
was Daniel and his friends against his
king. Exactly.
Now, what was the mindset of the eunuch?
The food that the king had supplied was
the best.
Mhm.
And Daniel said, "It's not the best."
And he was horrified.
So, today, if you decide to become a
vegetarian, there will be many a voice
which says, "Where are you going to get
your protein from?"
Yes. And what about B12?
And what about this and what about that?
And you're going to get weak.
The strongest person on the planet
is a vegan. Mhm. Vegetarian. The best
athletes are vegetarians. In fact, if
you want to compete on on that level in
the world today, you had best be a
vegetarian.
And uh I mean, this is common knowledge.
And we could show lots of those
interesting videos, but it's just a
fact. The mindset of man
just cannot comprehend
that flesh and plant
should have such a different reaction.
Now, my own research was
animal protein
versus plant protein and the effect on
the diseases and the health of of
humanity. That was what I did at
university.
And it always stunned me
that if you put in that plant protein
combination, a grain and a legume is a
complete protein. So, a simple thing
like a peanut butter sandwich is a
complete protein. And a better protein
that you ever get out of out of flesh.
And if you compared the the parameters,
the immune responses, the
uh cardiovascular responses, the
cholesterol levels, all of these things
with plant-based versus non-plant-based,
I mean, the differences were always
astounding.
Mhm.
So,
he thought that he would be worse off if
he changed his diet.
"Then you shall make me in danger my
head to the king."
And Daniel said to him, "Prove thy
servant, I beseech thee, 10 days."
Daniel said, "And let them give us pulse
to eat." That's plant material,
vegetarian.
"And water to drink. I don't want this
wine.
And let our countenances be looked upon
before thee, and the countenance of the
children that eat of the portion of the
king's meat." He was being compared
within the Israelite community.
Yes.
So, today, we have people
that have accepted the call.
And there are those that stubbornly
refuse to follow the Lord's directives.
And
those that follow
And if you compare them,
all those comparisons have been made.
The World Health Organization has made
comparisons like that. And the World
Health Organization, years ago, already
published that if your diet is more
plant-based,
then you are healthier than if it is
less plant-based.
"Then let our countenances be looked on
before thee, and the countenance of the
children that eat of the portion of the
king's meat, and as thou seest, deal
with thy servants." Do a test. A 10-day
test. Do you think 10 days can do it?
Indefinitely.
Well,
it doesn't seem logical.
Well, we have institutes, health
institutes today, that put you on a
10-day diet, and within 10 days,
the parameters are so vastly changed
Mhm.
that the people that are
part of this are stunned.
I have seen with my own eyes people that
cannot even walk 5 m without having to
sit down. They're in such a state at the
end of 10 days be transformed.
Unbelievable.
"So, he consented to them in this
matter, and proved them 10 days. And at
the end of the 10 days, their
countenances appeared fairer
and fatter in flesh than all the
children" These are the children of
Israel
"which did eat the portions of the
king's meat."
And we can confirm that today.
Um just two questions that I would like
to ask on Daniel. The first is the wine
that he didn't want to drink. Can you
elaborate on that for us? And then also,
there's also mentioning that the food
was offered to idols. Uh-huh.
Well,
he came from the royal family, right?
Mhm.
He was He was a prince.
And uh
the wine had been forbidden for the
priesthood.
Now, people obviously drank wine
and uh throughout history and even Noah
got drunk.
So, uh
there's no doubt that people drank
alcoholic beverages.
And the priesthood was forbidden to do
this. And Daniel had purposed in his
heart
that he did not want to defile himself
with these issues. Now, today
aren't God's people called the royal
priesthood? Mhm.
And uh the wine that Jesus
uh produced out of water He said the
wedding of in Cana.
That could not have been alcoholic.
Because if the bread was to be
unleavened, which was a symbol of sin,
then the wine also would have to be
unleavened. And Jesus spoke about uh
putting wine new wine into old wine
skins that they would burst. Yes. In
other words, why would they burst?
Because the bacteria that caused the
fermentation
are inside the old wine skin and would
cause a fermentation which would then
make then make them burst. So, in other
words, they would preserve so that they
would not ferment.
And it's also interesting that Jesus it
didn't ask for the wine jugs
to be filled with water.
He asked for the ritual cleansing stone
uh containers outside where you washed
your hands and your feet, which was a uh
uh
symbol of cleansing.
Mhm. That those should be filled with
water because he would give you a higher
cleansing, that of his blood. And the
difference between alcoholic wine
and just normal fruit juice. Yes. I've
actually
seen if the Bible talks negatively
about the wine, then it's
You have to get it out of the context.
Yes. Because the word is the same. It's
grape juice or it is fermented.
Yeah. So, obviously when the Bible talks
about uh pouring wine, woe to him who
gives wine, drinks wine drink to his
neighbor,
uh then it's alcoholic.
And when it is talking about new wine or
wine, you have to get it from the
context whether it is fermented or
unfermented.
wine and be merry
is not
the showing to alcoholic wine.
not. Haven't we come together and had uh
grape juice together and were merry?
Certainly.
It doesn't have to be alcoholic. In the
old days, it used to be alcoholic in my
life and I paid the price.
That's the thing. You see, if you if
you're a drinker and you drink and
there's and you drink a little bit and
you call it tipsy, you become tipsy, you
think it's being merry. But somebody
doesn't that doesn't drink at all don't
think you're merry. You see, you're
drunk. You're drunk and and you're
acting stupid. Correct. Yes.
So, Daniel was a type
of the people of the end. Daniel, the
name actually means judgment.
And
he was temperate in his ways and he was
vegetarian. He didn't eat the flesh
foods and he abstained from alcoholic
beverages.
Let's go to John the Baptist, who's
another type.
Sorry, just the other one,
idols, the food sacrificed to idols.
Now, that that is a uh an interesting
point because even the Council of
Jerusalem
confirmed that you shouldn't eat food
sacrificed to idols.
Now, uh
basically,
what happened in the old days
is the pagans would dedicate the food to
their gods.
And the disciples felt that you should
not eat that kind of food. Paul later on
clarifies it somewhat when Paul says uh
an idol is nothing.
It It doesn't really exist.
So, he makes a statement which is often
misconstrued. He said, "Therefore, if
your faith is weak, you will eat only
vegetables because the meat was
generally sacrificed to idols.
Now,
uh even in today's world, some religious
systems will
bless the food in a particular way.
And then the food gets stamped
as being blessed in a particular way. In
fact, even with the medications, it is
done like that. Many homeopathic
medicines, for example,
you have uh a chanting which takes place
to enforce
uh the vitality of the medication.
So, that is also dedicated, as you were,
to another entity.
Now, Paul says, "If your faith is weak,
then you will avoid all of those things.
But if your faith is strong, then you
will know that an idol is nothing. It
doesn't exist."
So, can you Can you then eat it or not?
Well, Paul says,
uh "If your faith is weak, you will
avoid it." So,
it was dedicated to idols
and
Paul says, "If your faith is strong,
then it shouldn't bother you
because you pray over it and you don't
worry about it. So, if we use modern
examples of foods that are dedicated to
other deities
and have stamps on them which say that
they are dedicated to other deities, if
my faith is weak, I might avoid them. If
I do not consider this as as you know,
biblically correct. But if my faith is
strong and there's a stamp let's say on
a bottle of herbs, I know it's herbs.
And I will say to God, "Thank you for
these herbs. Please bless my food and I
will eat it because my faith is strong."
So, it has nothing to do with uh flesh
meats necessarily. Uh it's also
interesting
that the Council in Jerusalem had said,
"Because Moses has been preached."
Uh in fact, the the slaughtering
ways
were already introduced because many
people realized the health benefits of
this. And even today, I mean, if you
take kosher meat, which is
meat that has been slaughtered according
to the Jewish ritual,
and you take halal meat,
it has been slaughtered according to the
same ritual.
So, uh
in the case of halal meat, there will be
an Imam who blesses the food as well.
So, you have that extra dimension, but
the the the slaughtering technique is
actually identical. The blood is
drained.
So, are you not going to eat the one if
you're going to eat meat now
uh as opposed to the other one? Is it
because of the dedication or is it
because of the way in which it was
slaughtered? So, that that is the issue
that people have a problem with.
John the Baptist,
Matthew 11:18, "For John came neither
eating nor drinking and they say he has
a devil."
A fascinating verse.
"The Son of Man came eating and drinking
and they say, 'Behold, a man gluttonous
and a winebibber, a friend of publicans
and sinners,
but wisdom is justified of her
children.'"
So, John the Baptist came
not eating and drinking. Well, obviously
he was eating and drinking something or
else he would have died, but he wasn't
eating the common foods.
Jesus, on the other hand,
was not sinning. He was without sin.
But within strict temperate
rules, he did not consider it a sin to
associate
with publicans and sinners whom he came
to save.
And he would eat at their tables
not in in a fashion which was contrary
to the law, but to reach the people
where they were.
But his representative
came not eating
or drinking.
And we read in the spirit of prophecy,
John separated himself from friends and
from the luxuries of life,
the simplicity of his dress.
I mean, Jesus referred to that. What did
you see in the desert?
Did you see a reed blowing in the wind?
No.
You saw
a
prophet
and more than a prophet.
Yes.
A garment woven of camel's hair was a
standing rebuke to the extravagance and
display of the Jewish priests. By the
way, it was not a skin. Mhm. No, it
wasn't.
It was a garment. It was woven from
camel's hair.
Beautiful. Yeah. His diet
purely vegetable. It's a very strange
statement.
of locusts and wild honey. So, obviously
here she understood that this word
locust, locusta, referred to the carob
bean.
Yeah. And the carob bean was what the
poorer people actually ate. It was
actually Pulse.
healthy food. It was a pulse, yes. Carob
bean. Uh
the the lost son,
he started eating what was given to the
pigs by the rich people. And uh you
know,
Yeah, the same today. I was once in
Germany
and uh
that was years ago. Today it's
different. They eat corn on the cob.
Mhm.
But in those days, they considered corn
to be something that was to be fed to
the pigs.
So, one of them said, "I will only eat
corn once it's gone through the pig." In
other words, while it once it's been
transferred into flesh of the pig.
So, this is the same case here. So, his
diet was purely vegetable consisting of
locusta, the carob bean, and wild honey,
which by the way is a plant product
because it's nectar, and it it's doesn't
go into the stomach of the bee. There's
a special chamber
where it is transferred into honey. So,
it it's not something that is
pre-digested.
Okay.
So, it is basically plant-based, and it
was a rebuke to the indulgence of
appetite and the gluttony that
everywhere prevailed. Remember, in those
terms, gluttony was mainly referred to
flesh eating.
And those who are to prepare the way for
the second coming of Christ are
represented by faithful Elijah. As John
came in the spirit of Elijah to prepare
the way of Christ's first advent,
the great subject of reform is to be
agitated. Temperance in all things is to
be connected with the message to turn
the people of God from their idolatry,
their gluttony, and their extravagance
in dress and other things.
In other words, when you become a
Christian,
everything has to change. You have to go
back to the Edenic thinking. Now,
there's this notion
that when you give up the ways of the
world, that you are somehow deprived.
"Oh, had we died in Egypt."
And yes, in the beginning you feel
deprived.
Yeah.
But as you start to learn
about the varieties of things that God
has given,
all the grains that we find in the
world, all the ways and means in which
you can make the most delightful foods,
the most delightful healthy milks from
seeds and nuts, and how you can create
uh
the most magnificent dishes using
plant-based material, once your
expertise improves,
then you cannot even imagine, at least I
can't,
that I used to live like I used to live.
Yeah, it was the same.
You were a You were a big meat eater,
weren't you?
Three times a day. Three times a day?
And
it's interesting what you're saying now.
It's also It's almost as if
God
you perceive that God always wants you
to have Everything he wants you to do is
uh it's inferior
Yeah, it's bad.
I and everything Satan brings towards
you,
uh this is the life, you know, the
eating, drinking, whatever I like.
So, it's something that has to change in
your mind. And how do you feel once
you've made that change?
It takes a It takes hard work, but I
cannot believe that I once
didn't
eat like we are eating at this rate.
go back to your original lifestyle?
No, never. I think I would I I would die
just of the thought.
Yeah.
So, something has to happen here.
And uh once you've made those changes,
once you've said, "Okay, God, I know
this is your will. This is hard for me.
I understand
that it's hard, but help me."
Do you think he'll help you? Oh,
definitely. Absolutely, and he'll send
you things across your path, and he'll
send uh recipes,
and some things that you start
experimenting with. I remember my wife,
she was in tears because
I said, "I I can't live like this.
Something has to happen."
And eventually, I came to the point I
said, "Okay. Okay, let's just take a
step back.
Let's just have good bread,
healthy spreads, and fruits until we
figure this thing out." Because the
taste you couldn't at the in the
beginning.
Yes.
That's one of the
the the things that
Your palate has to Yeah, your whole
palate has to change because everything
doesn't it's unfamiliar tastes. So, God
doesn't want any drug in your life.
Nothing that affects your mind. No
alcohol Mhm. because that affects your
discernment. I mean, that's obvious that
it affects your discernment, right?
Yep. Cuz your inhibitions go. What does
that mean? It means anything can tempt
you, right?
Yeah, and I used to I used to drink, and
you would always say, "Yeah, but I don't
drink to get drunk.
And I know when I'm drunk.
I the
proof is in the pudding.
Yes.
You don't actually know. Somebody that's
not drinking, he knows. Correct. Yes.
that drinks, even if you drink one
drink, you can you already have a
change, and you don't even realize it. I
once had to attend a a beach party. I
was uh
in a situation where I couldn't get out
of it. It was a family situation, and
there was a massive beach party on the
go.
And I was the only one not drinking.
Absolutely the only one. They were all
They were all smashed, right?
And I was sitting there, and the
conversation
You know, it drifts from the top to the
bottom,
and the conversation was at a level
where I thought, "My goodness."
And the contrast becomes so great.
And I was sitting there
and watching the people,
and this one lady,
she was
very drunk.
And she was walking around making all
kinds of statements. And then she walked
into
the sea,
and there were only tiny little waves.
It was very calm day with tiny little
waves.
And uh a a small little wave came and
knocked over.
And I watched,
and she didn't come up.
She didn't come up.
And I thought to myself, "Now, is she
playing a game? What is she doing?"
And then I thought to myself, "No, this
is not a game."
And I was fully dressed. I had clothes
on. I was the only one that didn't have
a beach attire on.
And I ran into the ocean
and
where she was, and I felt around, and
there she was. She was lying on the
bottom.
And I picked her up. Now, it wasn't very
long because I realized very quickly,
and I dragged her up, and she was
coughing and spluttering, and she didn't
even know that I'd taken her out of the
water.
And then she got up and walked back to
the bar and continued doing what she was
doing before. I don't know what happened
to her in her life,
but uh I just thank God that I was sober
that day. Yeah. So, these things, your
discernment goes, and it's very
important that we
that we understand that. So, what about
things like coffee?
There's a little video
which says what one cup of coffee can do
to you. Yes. And in the spirit of
prophecy, we read that we shouldn't be
drinking those things.
It's the most popular drug in the world.
I need that little boost. It's
everywhere, from 320 mg in a Starbucks
Caffe Grande, about the max you should
have in a day, to energy drinks, to
sodas, now even inhalable, 100 mg in an
instant. But could that daily dose of
caffeine be changing your brain? We
turned to researchers at Wake Forest in
North Carolina, where I underwent two
MRI brain scans. This first scan with no
caffeine in my system. Then I downed
just one drink. Now, my second MRI. This
was my brain before caffeine. This was
after. The difference was remarkable.
It's like a 40% drop in the blood flow
to your brain. So, that's a lot.
So, before caffeine, with caffeine, the
blood flow to my brain dropped about
40%. 40%.
Really?
Yes. Why the drop? Caffeine blocks a
chemical called adenosine, which
controls blood flow to the brain. Add
caffeine, blood vessels constrict, less
blood circulates in the brain, and your
blood pressure and heart rate go up. So,
if you skip your regular coffee, that
surging blood can trigger a caffeine
headache. It's like trying to get a fire
hose to pump blood up through your
skull. If you're a caffeine lover, your
brain has actually changed. It now
functions normally on caffeine. How much
caffeine do I have to drink to change
the physiology of my brain?
Not very much.
Not very much? Like even a cup a day?
a day will change your brains.
So, in other words, anything that
affects your mind
should not go into your into your mouth.
So, isn't that amazing? One cup and the
cup of coffee
one cup of coffee
and there's a 40% reduction
in the blood flow to your brain.
That means that there must be a
reduction also in your frontal lobe
capacity. You might be more alert,
but you don't have the same discernment
because of the way in which
the blood is channeled.
When the Spirit of Prophecy
has these quotations in it, they are
based on biblical criteria. Here's a
very interesting one.
There's no safety in eating the flesh of
dead animals.
And in a short time, the milk of cows
will also be excluded from the diet of
God's commandment-keeping people. In a
short time, it will not be safe to use
anything
that comes from the animal creation.
And today we know that diseases are
transferred from animal to animal. In
the old days, swine flu was swine flu.
Bird flu was bird flu. Horse flu was
horse flu. Foot and mouth disease
happened to cloven-hoofed animals,
right? Not anymore.
So, we have had trans-specific
transfer.
We call those zoonotic diseases and they
have just increased dramatically.
And even if you take the pandemic
that is sweeping the world
and if you want to accept that this is a
virus that occurred in the animal
kingdom, then it is a zoonotic transfer
if you want to accept that.
So, she says we cannot now do as we have
ventured to do in the past in regard to
meat-eating. It has always been a curse
to the human family, but now it is made
particularly so in the curse which God
has pronounced upon the herds of the
fields because of man's transgression
and sin.
This does not say
that
wild animals are more clean than caged
animals. No. And it's also interesting
that in many areas, there are
prohibitions on hunting
because of the various diseases that we
find in wild animals these days. So, it
doesn't matter how good you look after
your own
stock livestock. No.
According to this
the curse which God had pronounced upon
the herds of the field. Now, when it
comes to viral diseases
they will affect
a creature whether it is healthy,
receiving healthy food or not. Let's say
free-range animals. Viral diseases,
these zoonotic diseases, they will hit
those animals whether they are eating
healthy food or not.
The way the animal deals with it is a
different thing. So, if we have a
healthy lifestyle, we can deal with
diseases in a better fashion, but that
doesn't mean that I want to eat an
animal that can be a viral carrier. You
can be a carrier without any symptoms,
for example.
So, it's best to avoid these things.
Now, some statements seem a little bit
stronger than others, but in the light
of what Daniel's experience was
and he did not want to defile himself
with what was on the king's table
and he was to set an example.
And this was an example amongst God's
people, right?
And just take for example when they had
to bow down
to the image that Nebuchadnezzar had
erected. How many Israelites were in
that group?
And only three of them
did not bow down. The rest. That's
scary, isn't it? That's very scary.
That's very scary.
And it's always interesting to me that
Daniel said, "I do not want to decide
defile myself with the food that comes
from the king's table."
And as we saw, the eunuch thought that
that was the very best of food.
But Daniel realized it was the very
worst of food.
Now, when you go through
the kings of Israel
and the kings of Judah
and you study
their
their apostasy, for example, and their
life cycles
even those that died of natural causes
they died very early.
Obviously, they were very diseased.
And those that followed God's principles
had the opportunity to become very aged.
So, here's this interesting statement.
Let not any of our ministers set an evil
example in the eating of flesh meat.
Let them and their families live up to
the light of health reform.
We should all be little Daniels.
Let not our ministers animalize their
own nature and the nature of their
children. Children whose desires have
not been restrained or tempted not only
to indulge in the common habits of
intemperance
but to give loose rein to their lower
passions and to disregard purity and
virtue.
What you eat
is what you think.
Yes.
And what you think
is what you
makes up your character.
is what you are.
These are led on by Satan not only to
corrupt their own bodies, but to whisper
their evil communications to others. If
parents are blinded by sin
they will often fail to discern these
things.
Now,
what does the Spirit of Prophecy tell us
about coffee?
What then?
They visited with their brethren and at
the table revealed their principles by
eating meat
and drinking tea and coffee.
These men were not making that progress
in divine things that would make them
safe teachers.
So, as we discussed, any any drink or
food that contains a narcotic and
caffeine is a narcotic Yes.
affects your mind.
According to Wikipedia, it's the only
unregulated
narcotic drug.
Yes, you're absolutely right. It's the
only unregulated narcotic in the world.
And uh
in fact, people can't do without it. The
first thing they reach for is that in
the morning.
Now,
there are so many things that you can
drink. I mean, there are so many herbal
teas that you can drink. There are so
many delightful things that you can do.
You don't have to have a narcotic
blended with your drink to affect your
mind.
An interesting statement is this one.
At this stage of the earth's history,
meat-eating is dishonoring to God.
It is obvious that God took the children
of Israel and led them
to
think in the Edenic fashion. And God
will take the people at the end and will
do exactly the same thing.
It affects your mind. It affects your
thinking. It affects your temperance
and it affects your mood.
Irritability, all of those hormones,
those those fear hormones are in that
product.
Uh I don't know if you've ever been to
an abattoir. Have you been to an
abattoir? Yes, when I was younger.
Uh I used to work in them, of course,
because that was the nature of my
research.
And to see this
fear in these animals and all of those
those hormones that tend to create the
fight and flight mechanism and all of
those cortisones that are released,
those are all
issues that affect your your
temperament.
And particularly if you have an
aggressive nature, you should avoid
those kinds of things.
So, it is not unreasonable to say that
it is meat-eating and liquor drinking
that are making the world as it was in
the days of Noah.
I find it interesting that now with the
the lockdown
being slowly downgraded, liquor drinking
drinking was again introduced.
And you see these videos of this
massive excess. THEY'RE THEY'RE DOWNING
BOTTLES of brandy
as though it were water.
And I think to myself
this is what humanity is all about.
Where are the Daniels in this world?
How many people
will now die from accidents
because of
the use of alcohol. It's dishonoring to
God. There's no doubt about it. These
things are strengthening the lower
passions of the human being, animalizing
the race.
By giving way to base passions, man is
corrupting body, soul, and spirit.
The murders committed by men under the
influence of strong drink shows what a
cruel satanic spirit strong drink
inspires in man.
Often the liquor sold is adulterated.
Particularly in this day and age as
well. We read about it regularly.
And poisoned. And those who drink it are
made
mad. It affects your mind. And its
influence they show satanic ferocity.
They place themselves under Satan's
control and he works through them.
1 Corinthians 10:31.
Therefore, whether you eat or drink or
whatever you do, do all to the glory of
God.
So, the health message
that is so central to Adventism doesn't
mean that every Adventist is a health
reformer. In fact, the majority
are probably kicking against the gods.
But there is a blessing in it.
And
as for me
I can only say that
the blessing that I've received
from a changed lifestyle
is beyond computation.
Definitely. Same here. Energy levels.
Just on that part it's amazing already.
That
usually when I was sitting behind the
desk working for 5 6 hours
sitting and fishing there behind my
computer.
Now
I've never had that problem for the past
5 years.
to have that. I used to sleep there on
the floor
sometimes.
Uh
at the university
and just say, "Ah, I wish I could just
clear my mind."
And that dullness is gone.
And the blessings that one receives, as
you say, the energy. I'm not I'm not the
youngest person on the planet, but I can
still run up a mountain.
And many of my colleagues who are much
younger than me are are dead. Mhm. They
died of car- cardiovascular disease or
whatever. I mean, you can be hit by a
bus
tomorrow and you can be dead. That is
true.
But
the clarity of mind.
what I also would like to say. It's not
that
it's only the health. No. That's a a
plus. So, there are physical benefits.
There are spiritual benefits.
And there are temperament benefits.
And if you put them all into a package
then the health message is one of the
greatest blessings that God has given
humanity.
It was there in the beginning.
It will be there in the end.
There was a test of obedience on
appetite in the beginning.
Christ paid a tremendous price
to overcome that weakness in man's
behalf.
And that power to overcome he makes
available to God's children.
But we have to say yes.
And therefore, whether you eat
or drink
or whatever you do
do all to the glory of God. Yes. Amen.
Let's pray.
Our heavenly Father, thank you so much
for
giving us such beautiful truths. Please
bless us with these truths and help us
to implement it into our lives. And we
thank you in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe, click here. When the bell
appears, click and you will receive
notifications. To watch the next one,
click here.
Thank you again and see you next time.